a whoa whoa whoa wait did you see that
please
don't
[Music]
[Applause]
Sunshine welcome to another episode of
LED live everyone we're grateful that
you could join us on this Friday as many
of you do every Friday today we are
blessed with with a guest her name is
sha and she has a website called
Revelation for kids that's right.com all
right I got it right so we are going to
talk about the Book of Revelation a
little bit we're going to talk about her
Ministry a little bit and we're going to
talk about a film that your kids may
have seen we hope not but some of those
things that are in that film and how it
relates to the Book of Revelation so
welcome sha for coming on LED live with
us we're glad that you could be here
today thank you for having me so you're
you're presenting a movie like the Luca
I remember a lot of people were asking
us what about Luca this is like a beast
from the sea and things like that and I
was people were throwing out little
things but we didn't have a chance to
get into it and then I ran across your
page and I was like wow this is cool
like she's breaking down some stuff so
you're going to talk about that today
yeah we're going to talk about Luca and
I was uh you know I don't really watch a
lot of movies but um I like to travel
and I I've been to the Italian Riviera
and I was on a plane and none of my kids
were with me and they had that movie and
I was like you know sometimes I'm like
is there really a movie that's like okay
that really doesn't have any subliminal
messages and
everything and I don't know it's either
one way or the other it's hard the
jury's still out it's hard to find cuz
when I started watching it I couldn't
believe all the things that were in
there that paralleled um Revelation
interesting yeah wow yeah very
interesting let about that let's talk
about that so here's Luca so I thought
what we could do is we could do a little
quiz and I could uh give you guys a quiz
awesome let's do it pop quiz and um the
good news is you don't have to watch the
movie to take the quiz awesome and this
quiz is also on our website if you
wanted to you know download it and do it
for fun
cool okay so Luca so I'll give you a
little snippet of what's in the movie
movie and then we'll do the question so
Luca is a sea monster who comes out of
the sea to an Italian Seaside Town
interesting so does revelation mention a
beast coming out of the sea y yes it
does yes it does I saw a beast rise out
of the sea Revelation 131 and it comes
up near the Italian seaside yeah I mean
yes it does definitely a connection
there so luk Luka is a shepherd of fish
he holds a Shepherd staff a shepherd of
fish wow so who is the true Good
Shepherd that would be Jesus that would
be Jesus yeah I am the Good Shepherd the
Good Shepherd gives his life for the
Sheep John 1011 so does luuka wind up
sacrificing himself in any way for the
sheep for the other fish oh he actually
sells the fish out like he tells the
fishermen where to go and catch
what wow wow that's that's kind of the
opposite so here's a bonus question who
is the counterfeit Shepherd described as
the Sea Beast in Revelation chap 13 he
also carries a Shepherd staff wow so
this is like any ideas so a being that's
like Christ has the appearance of Christ
or something but is is not like an
antichrist character yeah so do you have
the answer cuz I do
I was asking Kei he looks I think I know
the answer okay that's I thought yeah no
I wasn't picturing thatan Mikey wow I'm
surprised well yeah I was I didn't put
together the the Shepherds so the
Bishops of Rome they carry this bishop
staff it's a symbol of authority and um
jurisdiction yep so all the reformers
identified the Beast out of the sea as
this papal system which arose in Rome in
Italy Italy and uh it's not the people
it's just the system and and the The
Authority so Luca's friend Alberto is a
sea monster too but he lives on the land
oh okay H nothing similar
there does revelation mention a beast
that comes out of the earth that works
with the Sea Beast wow yes it does sure
definitely and I beheld another Beast
coming out of the earth and he had two
horns like a lamb and he spoke as a
dragon Revelation 131 yeah W there's a
lot of different commentaries on
Revelation and and some people they
wonder you know since there's such an
emphasis on the sea that John sees with
this power you skip forward to the end
of the book and it says and there was no
more sea right and at the time that John
is writing what is he surrounded by by
this island and what is to him people
are wondering is this metaphorical on
many levels like
does the C represent that distance you
know in John's mind as well I'm not
saying that that's what that what it
means but is it is it a barrier in
John's mind to like man I'm I'm
separated from everyone that I love and
so they've they've kind of looked in and
weighed on that as well but it's it's
kind of interesting when you think about
it from that perspective here the sea is
this Great Divide between John and and
those he wants to minister to and that
you know at the end of the book it says
there is no more sea I'd never heard
that or thought of it that way that's
awesome yeah so while on Shore Luca and
Alberto are disguised as people no one
knows they are really sea monsters so
when they come out of the water and
they're dry they appear as people mhm
interesting do the beasts of the Sea and
the Earth in Revelation use
deception yes they
do wow they're masquerading as well yes
yes and Deception comes up all through
the Book of Revelation um the main two
ways that the devil works is through
coercion uh force and through deception
MH and he the Beast out of the sea
deceives them that dwell on the Earth by
the means of those Miracles which he had
power to do in the sight of the
Beast Revelation
13:14 so Alberto convinces him to
display to disobey his parent parents
and visit the world above isn't that
every Disney movie is that everywhere I
know my goodness every Disney movie it
really is every every
movie um yeah he really and um also I
didn't put this in here but the the
parents they um they tell him if he
doesn't obey them he's they're going to
send him to his like scary uncle in the
deep deep deep sea
wow so yeah you you break the
Commandment you you go to the bad place
that's another thing that the The Book
of Revelation brings out a lot is it
talks about the slander it talks about
the deceiver and you know and then it
reemphasizes or emphasizes quite a bit
about God's people um definitely towards
the end it says in the the Heavenly City
there will nothing enter it that makes a
lie it says of those people that they
have no gu in their mouth you know
really tries to drive home and emphasize
the point that nothing to do with lying
or deceiving is part of them and to show
that contrast between what was and what
God's ideal is for sure so I mean we
know but what does the Bible say about
disobeying parents just out of curiosity
what what did they do that I don't know
if you're going to cover what did the
parents say not to do that they ended up
doing they said not to go up to the town
they said don't leave the ocean wow like
don't go up to that world mhm that that
seems to be something I see a lot in
movies too like small foot it was about
this uh Yeti guy that they lived on the
top of a mountain and they were told
that if you go down there there's a
bunch of like evil people like don't go
down there Little Mermaid Little Mermaid
yeah all these things and I'm thinking
that that's like God's rule you know
it's like this is perfect garden for you
you know I made this perfect place for
you but Satan was like no God's keeping
something from you there's this
knowledge out there you know you know
and he tells that to people in different
circumstances I've I've read a couple
books Lately by people that were in
certain societies like one was she was
kind of a New York Society gal and she
hadd always been told like those
fundamentalists or those people that
live in the country they're kind of
weird and they they don't like us and d
and then during during the pandemic she
kind of like thought things were crazy
and they ended up moving out of the city
and next door to these people that were
supposed to be like oh stay away from
them and she's like they're super nice
wow so like was the opposite message of
and another lady who was into feminism
and you know the lesbian lifestyle and
everything and she was doing research
too about um those people that hate her
like why do they hate me and she ended
up being converted because the love of
God wow praise the Lord yeah we talk
about that too like the media anytime
Christianity is painted in a positive
light whether it's a wedding or we got
to exercise this demon it's always a
Catholic priest but any other time you
see Christianity they're always a geek
uh hater you know like they're the ones
that are protesting they're uneducated
you know and and like you said that's
just propaganda people are meeting these
people in real life and they're like
wait a minute that wasn't real real at
all right anyways yeah the Bible says
children obey your parents in the Lord
for this is right honor thy father and
mother which is the first commandment
with promise
that it may be well with thee and thou
mayest live long on the earth so there's
a promise with that um that's from
Ephesians so the grandma Grandma pagura
she's Luca's grandma she says breaking a
rule or two is part of growing up which
is standard Disney fair and from the
grandma from the grandma you got to
listen
to so um and what does the Bible say
about rule rules and life how rules are
connected to life like she's making it
say like to have that like abundant fun
life you have to break a few few rules
uh I'm thinking
like um this this is the laws of Liberty
and stuff you know that that's in James
those who keep the Commandments of God
will be blessed I mean I'm paraphrasing
of right absolutely so in Revelation
22:14 it says bless
those who do his Commandments that they
may have right to the tree of life and
may enter through the gates into the
city powerful verse uh Luca and Alberto
go fishing with masimo which is a friend
um they have this friend Julia and it's
her father so they're not catching any
fish and so they tell him where to catch
fish because they know where the fish
lives cuz he was The Shepherd of fish um
and then he catches all these fish so
it's kind of Twisted you know they're
making him out to be like a Christ
figure yeah but uh instead of taking
care of his
fish sacrificing the sacrificing the
fish wow is that is that guy holding a
shepherd's R is that like a fish hook or
that's yeah I'm not sure what he's
holding it just seems weird all the
symbology of this Shepherd's Rod when
they're fishermen but you see it over
and
over um and it's kind of interesting too
just the two beasts are friends with the
girl too they make friends with this
girl oh with the woman with the woman
wow the woman being a symbol of the
church in Revelation who told the
disciples where to catch fish when they
were having no luck that was Jesus was
Jesus so he said launch out into the
deep and let down your nets for a catch
and Simon said Master we've toiled all
night and caught nothing never Le
nevertheless at your word I will let
down the net and when they had done this
they caught a great number of fish and
their net was breaking Luke 54-6 and of
course we know that Jesus is using the
metaphor of fishing for men that he
wants to catch us not to um destroy us
or anything but to give us the Abundant
Life right so Luca and Alberto when they
get into the town they realize there's
this race and so they want to enter the
race they'll win a
vesa if you win the race what's a vesa
it's these Italian um motorbikes scooter
thing scooter things yeah and so uh are
we in a race also for a prize yeah Paul
says so that's what I was to saying yeah
so we are surrounded by so great a cloud
of witnesses let us lay aside every
weight and the sin which so easily ens
snares us and let us run with endurance
the race that is set before us there's
another verse too that says he who
endures will win a Crown of Life or
something right or he finish there's a
couple passages on on using the race
metaphor MH so here's a bonus question
the town is called Porto Rosa and the
race is called the Porto Rosa Roso cup
the red
cup so there's some red cups in the
bible really yes yeah the woman on the
Beast with the w cup of wine of
Abominations there you go yeah and then
there's also the cup um that Jesus had
that says this is my cup of the new yeah
so I saw a woman sitting on a Scarlet
Beast which was full of names of
blasphemy having seven heads and 10
horns the woman was arrayed in purple
and Scarlet and adorned with gold and
precious stones and Pearls having in her
hand a golden cup full of Abominations
and the filthiness of her
fornication and you know some of this is
kind of heavy if you're talking with
kids but basically what I like to talk
about like with forn is using the the
analogy of a um a married couple and if
one of those people goes off with some
other person and is Unfaithful then
that's fornication yeah um or if you're
not married and you go off and are um
sexually impure that's fornication yeah
and that God wants us to be married to
him that's right like and not be going
after other gods yeah in the same manner
he also took the cup after supper saying
this is the cup of the New Covenant in
my blood this do as often as you drink
it in remembrance of me wow that is
interesting the red cup the red cup yeah
and um obviously Jesus is giving us his
blood as a way to cover our sins and to
give us forgiveness okay so their enemy
is and race competitor is ercole an
arrogant and rude boy and this is
typical too in Disney like the
antagonist is often rude and arrogant
and this is the way that how does the
world often portray God yeah like
he uh hates certain Lifestyles and like
I don't know like bow or burn like do
what I say or else right it's this venge
you know you have to do what I say or
else I'm going to punish
you and this is a misrepresent
of who God is what is God really like
the Lord is gracious and full of
compassion slow to anger and great in
Mercy Psalms
1458 so the sea monsters they do end up
winning the race and as the rain comes
down so if they get wet they get um
transed transformed back to sea monsters
so as the rain comes down it starts
raining during the race their true
identities as sea monsters are revealed
what does rain symbolize in the Bible is
that the Holy Spirit the latter rain
yeah the latter rain um and also the
Bible and and it is the Holy Spirit and
the Bible says that the Holy Spirit
leads us to all truth yeah yeah I was
thinking rain some I think it was uh
represents Doctrine as well yes here it
is May my teaching or doctrine drop as
the rain my speech distill as the do
like the gentle rain upon the tender
grass and like shower upon the herb
Deuteronomy
32:2 it's time to seek the Lord till he
comes and Reigns righteousness on you
hoseah
10:12 that's pretty fascinating when the
rain comes then true character will be
revealed right seeing their monstrous
form yeah and God's people will be
revealed to be what they truly are yeahh
but in this movie I think it's painting
these monsters as oh they're they're
friends though you know that's coming
like oh I'm glad that everybody sees
their monsters because now they know
that they're really good right exactly
so that's what comes next so they're
revealed and also like half the people
in the town are revealed to be mon sea
monsters too and nobody knew it wow
interesting I didn't not know wow so
that reminds me of like the wheat and
the tears grow together
and then they'll be separated at the end
or we'll see the true colors at the end
yes well it's also ofy of uh we talk
about a lot on this show a movie called
Pleasantville right that's the name of
it yeah and so in the movie everybody
who it's a black and white world and
everybody who sins they get color and
there's a judge a judgment scene at the
end and the judge is wanting you know
this to all stop but the guy who's
questioning him who's basically like the
satanic character or whatever who's
saying that this color is good um he's
antagonizing the judge and the judge
yells and he turns colorful because he
let anger get to him and the guy puts
the mirror in his face and he's like
look you're you're a sinner too you're
and so it's just showing you know
there's a lot of us out there that um
you know all these good people out there
they're really Sinners too look at
they're all monsters so it's okay we
show our true colors if you look at the
the movie poster down at the bottom it
says nothing is as simple as black and
white so what they're doing is they
really addressing the issue of morality
or worldview or whatever in that and
just saying well you know to say
everything's black and white yeah and
you fast forward and you have movies
called like 50 Shades of Gray what is
that addressing same kind of thing right
one of those posters for 50 Shades of
Gray and this this is a great tie in
says no more rules and so when I do
seminars and I and I talk about these
kids films that are teaching this
concept of get rid get rid of the rules
do away with the rules all of that and I
say how far does that go right yeah it
goes that far that's how far it goes
yeah we were just talking about that on
another show I don't remember who the
guy was Harry Styles he was on the cover
right he was wearing a dress on the
cover of a magazine he was the first man
to ever be on a cover of a magazine of
this magazine it vogue vogue as a a a
man wearing a dress and it
says something about no no more rules
and in the article he's saying that he
tells everyone that rules in your life
are just putting these unnecessary
boundaries limits on you and I'm like so
how could you ever tell anybody they're
doing wrong whether that's under being
with somebody under AG or any of that
stuff it's like no don't put no limits
on me man you're the one telling me that
we shouldn't have rules m there's no you
can't draw a line if there's no rules
there's no rules I mean what they're
trying to eradicate is the concept of
sin yeah and um and who defines what's
right and wrong which was back to the
Garden of Eden right is that you can be
your own God and and decide what's right
and wrong and I think what we need to
understand is God Is Not uh imposing
these on
us God is the Creator and this is just
the way things are right mhm and it's
like gravity like you know if there's a
sign don't jump over this Cliff it's
because if you jump over it you're going
to fall and die the consequences and
it's not like he's pushing you over
right but if you're like no I don't
believe you I can do whatever I want
there's no Cliff there's no gravity
there's no Cliff I mean the thing is
it's coming and he's wanting to protect
everyone from jumping over the cliff
right yeah great analogy it's like
destroying the sign that says mning
Cliff
yeah so does the bible call us to be
okay so everyone celebrates that there
it doesn't matter what you look like it
doesn't matter if you're uh a sea
monster or not or if you're doing
whatever like you said whatever you want
to do it's okay does the bible call us
to be United sin or no sin like it's
okay
everything no which is why we go back to
that original thing I was saying at the
end of Revelation it it talks about a
multitude of things it says will not be
a part of God's Kingdom so God is the
one Drawing the Line it's not it's not
me I don't have the right to do that but
he's doing it because God is a consuming
fire no and so for and God is coming to
live with us and in order for you to
survive in that consuming fire he
consumes all sin yep so if you've held
on to sin you'll be consumed with your
yeah but if you've given that sin to him
and let him wash you clean then you can
survive in that fire and God is love so
when God says that what he's saying in
addition to that is he's saying these
things aren't love right you might think
that they are but they're not love and
they won't produce love right so the
Bible does say therefore come out from
among them and be separate says the Lord
do not touch what is unclean and I will
receive you 2 Corinthians
6:17 and it also says you know Jesus
said do you suppose that I came to give
peace on Earth I tell you not at all but
rather division Luke 12:51 yeah I'm
thinking of some of the verses like to
be in the world but not of the world and
um yeah we're we're not supposed to stay
in a little Christian bubble we're
supposed to go out and witness but we're
not supposed to be around them so long
that they influence us you know we have
to be a light in the world and it it
might not just be that we're supposed to
separate from each other we're supposed
to separate from sin that's what we're
really supposed to separate from and he
said to them you are from beneath I am
from above you are of this world I am
not of this world therefore I said to
you that you will die in your sins for
if you do not believe that I am he you
will die in your sins John 8:23 to 24
and that's what he came to rescue us
from and to give us life with that
concept you know it makes me think like
if we were to turn the TV off for the
rest of the day if you saw a commandment
broken people probably wouldn't watch TV
there's nothing to watch you have to
make sure it's like on animal just
animal videos or something but well even
in that you're watching the effects of
sin yeah yeah yeah yeah but the
beautiful thing about you know the Bible
and Jesus and this this beautiful good
news is for as the heavens are high
above the Earth so great is his Mercy
towards those who fear Him as far as the
East is from the West so far has he
removed our transgressions from us Psalm
1031 to14 amen cuz we've all sinned
we've all done those things um there's
no exceptions that's right so Jesus
Jesus except Jesus and he removes our
sins that that presentation you just
just gave how do you is that on your
website can I can put it on there it's
not there yet I just did it for today oh
wow okay I mean I have I do have a
article on there so if you look up
Revelation for kids and do in the search
bar Luca okay you'll pull up um some
stuff about it so there is like and you
can download the quiz yeah it's just in
a different format gotcha okay this is
from my blog so I have a lot of blog
posts for parents if you want to just
look up different topics that's an
ongoing updated thing okay and then
these are some of the videos we have on
on our YouTube channel super cool and we
have digital stuff so you can download
digital like coloring pages and uh
coloring books and that kind of stuff
very nice so tell us um a little bit
about Revelation for kids how did this
get
started well it's kind of a long story
but um because some people they kind of
laugh when they're like Revelation for
kids like couldn't you have started with
an easier topic there's so many of those
out there though that's what I was
thinking like I think it's amazing that
you went straight for the jugular like
the one thing that's not out there we're
living in the last days I think it's
important for kids to understand what
the Book of Revelation is about it's not
really scary it's about that Jesus is
coming and so I didn't start with kids
um first of all I started doing a
revelation study with women and um what
I found out through that process was I
was trying to share my Revelation study
with other Christian women like hey you
should do this bible study on Revelation
and I got a lot of push back like oh
that's kind of scary or I don't like to
study the end times or Revelation gives
me nightmares and so from that I thought
like where does that come from yeah and
um how do we introduce our kids to
Revelation and Bible prophecy in a way
that they're not scared to continue
studying it when they get older yeah
it's a great idea so what kind of things
do you do do you have I mean it looks
like we have some materials on the table
yeah so I'm uh right now we're putting
together a series of workbooks on the
Book of Revelation that go chapter by
chapter wow and it's going to be a
series of like seven workbooks right now
we have the first two wow okay so the
first one's on the seven churches the
second one is on the Seven Seals so it's
got activity pages and like crossword
puzzles and the idea is that they know
what's in the Bible so by the time
they're done they'll actually have read
the whole book of Revelation in kind of
small pieces yeah that's great and so I
think when we when we get them to learn
what's real and what's in the Bible then
you're more able to discern um
deceptions when they come up do you know
what your target age is for these for
these books it's like 8 to 12 years age
of age I think that's a great age
because it seems like that that age
group is really hard to reach like the
little toddlers you know puppets and
little cartoons and stuff but when
they're in that age they're kind of like
Ah that's kids stuff but they don't want
to sit in the church either or it's kind
of over their head so this is really
cool I'm glad that you're shooting for
that age so I homeschooled my kids for a
while so I kind of come at it as a
homeschooler and what I thought you know
worked well for us MH so it's really
something that the parents or the
teacher doesn't have to do a lot of
prepar a awesome parents like that you
can just if you have a Bible and you can
just give them here do lesson one and
they can do it on their own also uh
Sabbath or Sunday school teachers like
that as well because I know I I was in a
position where I was once a month I had
the opportunity which to me is an honor
an opportunity to get to talk to the
kids who were like 10 to 14 but it was
like it was kind of stressful when the
day was coming up I was like man what am
I going to say like how do I reach these
kids so this is cool to have a material
that is ready for you like that I've had
a lot of uh Sunday school teachers
Sabbath School teachers uh home school
moms and stuff that have enjoyed it but
also adults they're like oh I need that
yeah I like that there's questions in
here I like that there's activities that
reinforce learning and all that so that
that's great I was going to ask you
about the if you a homeschool mom or a
teacher prior because it looked pretty
well put together so and the other thing
I wanted to really um um is do is teach
kids how to study the Bible what does
that look like so all the questions are
there's not a lot of commentary there's
a little bit but a lot of it is the
questions you have to look up the text
in the Bible and answer it from the
Bible super cool so if you find
Revelations
scary and you're not sure this sounds
like it would be a great resource for
you cuz it's going to take you at a very
easy to digest pace and and I think this
is a great way to learn this is good
stuff I've studied with my kids kids
material too and found myself going like
wow I didn't know that that was really
neat I was going to say the same thing
those blue books those Bible books
reading Garden of Eden and stuff I was
like wow this like really puts me in the
story sometimes you just read it and you
kind of just read past stuff or there's
not really a whole lot there but when I
don't know sometimes PE some people like
really expound on what it was like in
the garden you know or yeah yeah and
there's a lot of kids material for the
Bible stories like I don't know if
you've like read a lot of Bible story
books but there's a lot and and that's a
good foundation like it's good to do
that before you get to Revelation but
then in the kids book it's like
Revelation uh Jesus comes you
know we skip over a lot so you're on
YouTube and Facebook and Instagram you
have a website yes okay so make sure you
check out Revelation forkids.com M get
some resources there were there's
anything else you wanted to share about
your ministry that you do um yeah so I
just wanted to mention like there's more
workbooks coming out just if you want to
sign up for our newsletter you can get
on our mailing list and get updates
about when it's ready the next one on
the Seven Seals I mean the seven
trumpets should be coming out later this
summer okay and um we have a new book
it's not quite published but it's hot
off the press um soon
um it's an ABC book for kids cool and
it's called M is for Mountain I just
have a couple samples be is for Babylon
wow I love the art babylon's a place
where people are proud and hottie the
New Jerusalem is the city we want to
live in let's get out of Babylon it'll
be destroyed I love it so again wanting
to introduce kids to these Concepts but
in a child friendly way in what age
range would you say so this book would
be I would say like
most alphabet six to eight or you know
those first kindergarten first second
grade okay yeah I think although it has
some it has some Concepts in it that are
even for Early Elementary School okay
this is see it's for crowns for kings
and for winners a crown is waiting for
you for being faithful to
Jesus D is for Dragon you know there's
so much dragons like for kids and it's
all
friend with your dragon MH so the dragon
or serpent is full of Deceit he Sly and
he lies and he's called the devil and
Satan beware of friendly dragons they
are not what they seem Jesus can protect
you from his evil schemes oh I like this
rhyming too yeah so we need to get the
kids when they're young to get these
other truths in in their minds very nice
F is for frogs like the Frog plague in
Egypt these frogs go everywhere they are
spirits of devils causing Havoc during
the sixth plague of Revelation they use
lies from the mouth to cause people to
fight against the most high god oh so
yeah we're trying to just get those
truth you know seeds planted no that's
great I mean kids kids will absorb a lot
when they're young and these are great
lessons for them to uh start on because
I mean hey we are living in the last
days
to know it's part of the bigger picture
I me and if you're an adult and you're
scared of studying Revelation this is a
great way for you to start too so I
would encourage you to even start with
what seems like a kids book and you
would be surprised how much you will
learn and absorb and of course you can
go beyond that I think I visited your
website and was looking at some of your
Source material and you'd dug into some
commentaries like uh stanovic book and
things like that so yeah so a lot of the
articles are for parents because uh in
order to teach your kids you kind of
need to learn it yourself but I don't
want people to be intimidated by that so
I'm trying to provide materials they can
use no this is great easily digestable
and friendly so well thank you all for
joining us on another episode of LED
live and encourage you to visit Sha's
website Revelation forkids.com and see
what you can learn there uh she has
downloadable resources so partake of
those and we hope that you have learned
today a little something you may have
have not seen before um you know these
films that are put out by big companies
like Pixar and Warner Brothers and
DreamWorks and things especially when
they're targeted kids you find they have
similar themes like breaking the rules
doing away with the rules and and then
here we have scenes that are very
similar to the things that we see in the
Book of Revelation so they're there and
it's not that we're um necessarily
indicating that every single person is
directly inspired by Satan but we think
that you're going to be inspired by one
of two Spirits you know and that's is
your life following God is your not is
your life not following God and so
depending on the course of your life
you're going to be influenced by one or
the other the good news is God can reach
you anywhere and he can reach those
people that are putting these things
together as well so we want to continue
to pray for them
and hope that God will lead them to
create better content so make sure you
support us at
ls. you can also support us on patreon
make sure you give this video a like uh
comment on it if you learned something
new uh subscribe to our Channel if
you've never been here before check out
our website little light studios. TV and
of course another way you can help
support us is by going to lightwear do
shop where we have some cool shirts like
the one Mike is wearing and the one I'm
wearing and you can pick those up there
so thank you and we will see you next
time do you have questions about the
Bible that you've been struggling to
find the answers for video Bible study
or VBS for short is a YouTube channel
that answers your Bible questions in 5
minutes or less check out these easy to
understand comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year And
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your journey
it's proven that people remember things
that they see more than what they hear
lightwear believes the best way to share
your witness is to wear your witness
lightwear has all kinds of graphic te's
that are great attention grabbing way to
share the gospel so head on over to
lightwear do shop and check out all the
cool graphic te's what do you want
people to remember when they see you
[Music]
oh